قتلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه ثلاثه
فلسطينيين واعتقلت رابعا في ضحيه اكتابه
شرق مدينه طول كرن بالضفه الغربيه واكد
شهود عيان ان قوات الاحتلال اطلقت الرصاصه
على الفلسطينيين الثلاثه مباشره في الراس
وكانت قوات خاصه اسرائيليه تسللت الى
الضاحيه بهدف اعتقال مطلوبين حيث وقعت
اشتباكات مسلحه مع مقاومين في المدينه
وهذه الصور هي نشرت
للاشتباكات التي حصلت
وسقط فيها ثلاثه مقومين كما نتابع هناك
شخص على الارض بينما جندي اسرائيلي يحتمي
خلف هذا الساتر او الحائط وواضح بانه يطلق
النار بهذا
الاتجاه
وهناك شخص ملقى على الارض
رايناه يجري ومن ثم يسقط جراء اطلاق النار
عليه اذا هذه الصور
للاشتباكات التي حصلت هذه اليه عسكريه
اسرائيليه تدهس جثه على الارض واضح تماما
عمليه دهس بعد ان اطلقت النار هنا بدايه
الاشتباكات جنود الاحتلال يطلقون النيران
واضح سقوط
ثلاثه مقاومين
فلسطينيين احدهم داخل هذا المراب على ما
يبدو واثنان على الطريق
ويستمر الجندي الاسرائيلي باطلاق النار
والاحتماء خلف هذا الحائط
ا مراسلنا ليث جعار ينضم الينا من طول كرم
وافنا ليث قبل قليل بان قوات الاحتلال
تقتحم بلده بني نعيم شرق الخليل وسط
موجهات واطلاق رصاص
وايضا ايضا عمليات اخرى متفرقه في الضفه
الغربيه اطلعنا اولا على تفاصيل ما نتابعه
الان من اشتباكات وعمليه قتل لمقاومين
فلسطينين في طول
كرم نعم بالفعل قبل الحديث عن ما جرى قبل
حوالي ل ساعتين من الان ننوه الى هذا
الخبر العاجل باقتحام قوات الاحتلال من
جديد مدينه طولكرم من بوابه 104 في هذه
الاثناء حيث بدات بالفعل دخول التعزيزات
العسكريه والاليات العسكريه نحو مدينه طول
كرم في هذه اللحظات ما جرى قبل حوالي
ساعتين من الان قوات خاصه اسرائيليه تسللت
الى ضاحيه كتابه شمال مدينه طول كرم
شماليه الضفه الغربيه المحتل حيث بدات
بمحاصرته هذا الاقتحام اشتباكات مسلحه ما
بين المقاومين وقوات الاحتلال حيث تم
تصفيه واعدام ثلاثه مقاومين فيما اعتقل
الاحتلال مواطن وشاب من تلك المنطقه ومن
ثم نقله الى جهه مجهوله اعتق استشهد في
هذه العمليه العسكريه الشهيد يوسف خولي
اثنين 20 عاما وايضا عاهد موسى 23 عاما
وطارق شاهين 24 عاما خلال هذه العمليه
العسكريه قوات الاحتلال حاصرت المنزل دفعت
بال التعزيزات العسكريه تم تصفيه الشهيدين
بدم بارد وبشكل مباشر الشهداء حيث قامت
اليات الاحتلال بدهس الشهداء بعد اعدامهم
على الفور واثناء انسحاب جيش الاحت للال
من مدينه طول كارم تم نقل الشهداء هنا الى
مستشفى ثابت ثابت الحكومي حيث نتواجد في
هذه اللحظات وتم التعرف على شهيدين فيما
لا يعني فيما بعد وبعد ساعه من استشهادهم
تم التعرف على الشهيد الثالث حيث انه يعني
في منظر يعني كبير جدا ومنظر مؤثر جدا
نتيجه لدهس ودهس راسه من قبل احدى الاليات
العسكريه اثناء انسحاب جيش الاحتلال ثلاثه
شهداء استشهدوا في عمليه عسكريه ليرتفع
عدد الشهداء منذ السابع من اكتوبر الى 340
شهيدا في الضفه الغربيه المحتله في هذا
اليوم كان هناك عمليه اغتيال على غرار ما
جرى امس خلال اقتحام جيش الاحتلال لمدينه
جنين حيث تم استهداف سبعه فلسطينيين من
بينهم اربعه اشقاء ايه في قريه الشهداء في
مدينه جنين في هذا اليوم ومقدمه على ما
يبدو لعمليه او لليله ساخنه في مدينه طول
كرم وفي الضفه الغربيه المحتله بالتزامن
مع ذلك هناك اقتحامات واسعه لعدد من
المناطق في الضفه الغربيه المحتله في
مدينه الخليل التي تشهد مواجهات واشتباكات
مع قوات الاحتلال ايضا في مدينه طولكرم
وتحديدا في بلده قفين الى الشمال من مدينه
طول كارم حيث قبل ساعه من الان نعم مع اذا
الانباء حول
تجدد الاقتحامات من جانب القوات
الاسرائيليه لمدينه طول كرن بالضفه
الغربيه سنترك لجمع المعلومات وسنعود اليك
لنتابع هذا الخبر على راس الساعه المقبله
ستبقى معنا ليث سنعود اليك لمتابعه
الانباء الوارده من الضفه الغربيه
واعاده قوات الاحتلال اقتحام طول كرم